[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
kirk kerbstreet espn college football
analyst herbie how is your day
i'm good man how you doing well i've had
better days uh had a bad day yesterday
and it's continued today we've lost the
key to carson palmer's heisman
uh you know the container we sent the
box back to him he loaned us his heisman
for about a year
and then we sent it back
and he wanted it for the college
football hall of fame induction and he
has the case he doesn't have the key to
open it up
oh my gosh
i know what are you gonna do you can't
you can't uh is it too late get it to
him do you know because you guys do the
heisman show and do you know if there is
one key that fits all heisman suitcases
well you know there's only one person
that you can ask that too and that's the
commissioner of college athletics that's
chris fowler so i he i have no idea at
all how that works chris is
intimately involved in the heisman
i'm just merely a pawn polly can you
check with fowler or fritzy and just see
yeah is there a key that will open that
up so i can get this to cars i don't
want him to break open that suitcase
with the heisman there but
that's
that
that's my problem you're working the
heisman show aren't you
no no
last year it's it's um it's a honestly a
blessing because we do army navy
um
that same day and all these years we
would do army navy with college game day
whether we're in baltimore or philly or
this case
in new jersey it met life
and then we would leave we'd go back and
you know you'd love to do the heisman
but lee and i you know we're in the back
of the room ask a couple questions and
it's really fowler and and the four or
five finalists it's really their show
well we uh last year got off of it and
we got to stay for two years ago we got
to stay for army navy
and um first time all these years of
doing game day in the morning never got
to stay and it's such a cool scene
and um so no this year i'll be
i'll be there again watching uh army and
navy fired up the uh home depot show uh
college game day army navy will be at
metlife stadium they'll be there this
saturday 9 a.m until noon eastern i tell
people if you get any opportunity to go
to a army game i haven't i haven't been
to a navy game at navy but i've been to
west point quite a few times and uh i've
been to the army navy game as well
there's just something magical about it
um
you know when
whenever you start to feel bad about who
we are or what's going on in our country
just just go and you see
you know there's so many positive things
we still got a shot here
that's true
you're reminded of like oh my gosh this
is incredible you know to see these guys
and girls what they're doing it's
impressive i brought this up earlier in
the show and i don't know if it happens
anytime soon but i i wonder with name
image and likeness like kenny pickett at
pitt what if he said to the peach bowl
hey
i don't you know you pay me 50 000 i'll
play in the game if not i'm gonna get
ready for the draft
that it's it's not a meaningful game and
maybe the fact that we're going to
expand the playoffs here soon but
you know christian mccaffrey did it what
six years ago leonard fournette people
freaked out you know kayvon thibodeau is
gonna sit out nobody's gonna care about
that i just wonder if
does it benefit kenny pickett to play in
this peach bowl game
um it just depends on how you're wired i
i'm not going to try to say these guys
should or should not play i i'm from a
different generation you know like you
um i i try to do the best i can you know
i have four boys that are all 21 and
younger i mean i i get this generation
it's not like i have my head in the sand
but i don't have to agree with it
um katy pickett and pitt are in
unchartered waters i mean you say the
peach bowl like we're saying the blue
bonnet bowl
that's a huge game for that school and
for kenny pickett who is the leader
of that team
i haven't heard him speak i have no idea
what his intentions are
but to me there's something about
putting on a uniform one last time with
your boys
and going out and competing
that outweighs this is just me
that would outweigh you just played 12
games some some cases 13 games
um and now you're going to say
i'm not going to play in this last game
to get ready for the draft if that's how
you feel then then more power to you
but um i i think you have to look at it
at a kind of a case-by-case basis the
fact that mario cristobal left oregon
he's the head coach of miami
uh thibodeau decides that he's going to
forgo and that's not really a shocker
there yeah but i i would be
really surprised if kenny pickett
doesn't play in that bowl game for pitt
with the year that they've had
what did you make of his fake slide
um
if if i'm a defensive coach
i i
i'm gonna i'm just gonna start laying
quarterbacks out and deal with the
consequences because he he clearly
started to go into slide mode
give him credit for his instincts you
know he's not really known for his feet
and his athletic ability out in the open
field he's he's known for what he can do
in the pocket throwing the ball around
but he got out there and
he started out as you know he started to
go down and the safety's pulled up
and then he recognized that it was
almost like you were in practice you
know the whistle blew and and it was the
end of a period but the defender if i if
i'm a coach and i see that film even if
it wasn't my team
i'm going to use that as a copy to show
like until he's down you you lay him out
i mean people you know how it is when a
quarterback's in the open field it's
like
it's like every bunch of great white
sharks trying to go get some chum i mean
they're trying to not just bring him
down they want to they want to end his
day
and so you know i i think after seeing
that the reaction i've heard from a lot
of guys that play defense is
you know the whole reason they got us
pulling up is so these guys are going to
go down and now he pulls that
no more you know that that kind of
attitude why did so many people doubt
nick saban this past weekend
well
because we've watched them play all year
and they haven't lived up to their
their own standards you know and so i
think a lot of us thought
something's not quite right yeah bryce
young's a phenom jameson williams a
phenom the offensive lines got has some
major issues not one week or two weeks
but all year they've had some concerns
and bryce young's athletic abilities
kind of pulled him out where he's had to
scramble to throw and now they're
playing georgia the one team that's been
consistent all year defensively
um i think a lot of people just knew
that nick saban's team they never show
up to a stadium as an underdog you knew
they'd have a chip on their shoulder but
was it going to be enough
to beat that georgia team that we've
watched only team
all year that's been consistent you know
sometimes you let up you survive a game
georgia didn't have that they were
consistent all year long so it was
really more of
not doubting nick saban but the respect
you have for georgia and then we were
reminded pretty quickly it's still nick
saban in his prime standing on that
sideline bill knows how to get his team
ready to play in these big games so
um we were all
i think we apologized on sunday uh for
doubting him
cincinnati i think what you count on you
can count on one hand how many times
we've doubted him since 2008.
well you were part of the rat poison
i was yes yes i'm usually part of the
rap poison giving him too much uh you
know respect and to me too many
compliments isn't that amazing though
saban rails on us if we say nice things
about his team and then he rails on you
when you don't say so he's just using
the media
oh for sure did a great job
he did he does and i knew i knew he was
going to use that and i knew
think about that alabama roster every
game they play
coach is guarding against complacency
literally every game they play
you know he the outside noise is
alabama's going to win they're going to
win they're going to win
and finally
you saw him in the iron bowl i mean they
very easily and should have lost that
game to auburn who's not having a great
year it's a rivalry game they're down
ten nothing like eight minutes to go if
tank bixby gets a first down the game's
over and they lose in the final minute
of game but he comes up a yard short so
auburn has to punt and bryce young ends
up leading him on a long you know 90
whatever it was five yard touchdown
drive
in a really a heisman moment for him but
that's how they looked the week before
almost stumbling around
and so it wasn't that far-fetched but
you just knew
he would have that nobody believes
nobody believes you can play with this
georgia team
and they showed up they have not looked
like that all year and of course they
save it for the biggest stage of the
year
talking to kirk kerb street college game
day we'll be at army navy metlife
stadium this saturday 9 a.m until noon
and herbie also part of the college
football playoff semis in the national
title game january 11th um
cincinnati's chances better chance
against alabama or georgia
um
i think cincinnati
has a chance in this game because of the
way they played defense and i think if
they played georgia they would probably
have a little bit of a better chance
just because of the how explosive bryce
young and jameson williams can be in the
passing game john michie you probably as
you know that number eight
he's out you know he's torn his acl he
was such a great compliment
to the vertical stretch of what williams
could do down field he was always
underneath on on slants and little
outside routes and just finding space so
you had to be worried about about both
of them because he was more yards after
the catch you take that away
luke fickle is a defensive oriented
minded coach
he's got a veteran defense that went
toe-to-toe with georgia
one year ago in in their bowl game and
and i think it gave him a lot of
confidence coming into this year
um i i think people that are
could name two players on the cincinnati
roster and probably think cincinnati's
gonna get killed
i i would be careful there i don't i
don't i just don't see that i think
cincinnati you know desmond ritter the
quarterback's been around played in a
lot of big games
um they've got a running back in jerome
ford who actually was you know played
big time football at alabama before he
transferred over
and they're going to show up it's going
to be the shoes on the other foot
going back to alabama always being
complimented oh you're going to win by
20 no problem and cincinnati is going to
show up with an attitude cincinnati's
going to show up feeling disrespected
and uh will it again be enough we'll
have to see but i see that game being
competitive uh more so than getting ugly
is there a tactful way for these coaches
to leave
for one another job like could brian
kelly have done it differently that
would have appeased more people
yeah i
i think
the challenge i think people
don't understand is the the recruiting
aspect of it and the timing of the
recruiting the early signing periods is
a week from tomorrow these athletic
directors you know they're they're
running a quote-unquote tempo offense
to try to make a good hire to get a guy
to a podium win the press conference and
then literally walk out of that press
conference and into a into a high school
and start recruiting and so there there
is urgency on on excuse me the usc side
or
you know the notre dame side or the lsu
side there's urgency to try to make a
hire
because you want to get the right guy
and and
try to salvage the recruiting class
what what
we always focus on is how does brian
kelly leave his team like that how does
lincoln riley leave his team like that
so for me
because i talk with a lot of these
athletic directors and coaches
kind of behind the scenes um you know
these in the month late latter part of
november and december
it's a little bit of a game because they
want to be respectful of the coach
trying to finish his season
in and you know in luke fickle's case he
was so locked in on what his team was
trying to do i think ultimately he he
could have had his choices of usc of lsu
of notre dame and potentially of
oklahoma
and he was so focused on what his team
was doing
he was letting jimmy sexton know listen
man i
i don't want to go there i don't i don't
well you're going to miss out on this
job okay
i'm i'm and i really in today's day and
age you got to really respect he wasn't
just a candidate i mean he was the front
runner for every one of those jobs and
he and he just wanted to finish the race
so it cost him all these jobs because of
the timing
um
and and how do you do it tactfully i
think you
you finish your regular season if you go
to a conference championship you know
you have your agent or whoever talking
to the ad say how he's coming
let him get to the finish line you get
to the finish line if you qualify for a
you know the playoff
you go do your press conference at your
new school you start to put the staff
together behind the scenes
and then you go back and and try to
finish the playoff like that that's what
ideally i would love to see
you imagine if notre dame if there were
some upsets in front of them and somehow
some
someway
notre dame made the playoff
uh marcus freeman's first game as the
head coach would have been
in a playoff because of what happened so
it's weird i i don't know if there's a
the perfect way to do it um but but i
think the recruiting aspect of it and
trying to like in oklahoma's case quit
the
they were hemorrhaging you know losing
recruits
their brand was just you know getting
lapped by the day
they had to make a hire and and do it
quickly and you know they eventually got
their guy but yeah it's it's a it's very
messy uh because i think because of the
timing more than anything
yeah i wondered if oklahoma was going to
match from what i was told that lincoln
riley wasn't going to go to lsu lsu
thought they had him he went back to
oklahoma and said hey you want to match
this and they said no
and then somebody caught wind of it with
usc they swoop in and then all of a
sudden they hire lincoln riley oklahoma
going to regret not matching that lsu
offer
well and i don't know if there's a
hundred percent truth to that i i i'm
really heavily involved with a lot of
these guys and and the and the agents
and ads and i i you know mike bond had
the most time event mike bone had the
most time of anybody the the ad at usc
and i think he had
kind of his a list of five or six guys
from from word go which was i can't
remember when clay helton got let go i
mean it was way way way back and he was
he was swinging for the fences from the
beginning behind behind closed doors
and i know that that uh lincoln was a
name that he kind of on his dream list
of guys like dabo and like huge names
and i think you know
when exactly lincoln found out
is debatable and all that and i'm not
going to speculate but i i think
oklahoma felt
they did match
they were the sunday after the bedlam
they were doing everything they could
with joe castiglione and their president
trying to say listen listen let us let
us try to do this we'll get you this
we'll get you that
and from what i understand it was more
nothing against oklahoma and nothing
against what they weren't doing and
nothing against going eventually to the
sec
i think it was just a change i think it
was a new challenge going to la
and and coaching at usc i think it was
just it was more about what that had to
offer
than it was what's lacking at oklahoma
so
uh and then you know they went out and
found a former assistant and coordinator
and brett venables and you know i think
both sides end up in a good spot but of
course we won't really know until we're
three or four years down the road from
now but not all of them all of them
always work out that's for sure herbie
great to talk to you my best to the guys
and uh have fun this weekend with army
and navy
i thought of you when the flyers had
that big win and any time ud wins a big
game i think of you with with hoops
because i go back as a kid to rosie
chapman
and some of those teams that they had
you know i was like in middle school and
those those ud teams and i just fell in
love at a young age don donahue and
then miguel knight and that group i mean
ud's always been always been a fun brand
to watch an easy team to pull for so
that was a great win hopefully they have
a big a big year this year thank you
herbie good to talk to you safe travels
okay you guys holiday take care fellas
kirk kerb street